الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
تعلن ارتقاء شهداء عشرات الجرحى في جنين
والبيره وذلك خلال تنفيذ قوات الاحتلال
اوسع عمليه عسكريه لها في جنين منذ عام
2002 المقاومه الفلسطينيه في جنين تعلن
عطب اليات العسكريه واصابات في صفوف
الاحتلال والغرفه المشتركه لفصائل
المقاومه في غزه تدعو المقاومين للاستعداد
للرد على العدوان حاله قرر الاحتلال
مواصله جريمته بحق جنين في سياق متصل
الناطق باسم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقول
ان العمليه العسكريه تتم بمشاركه نحو الف
جندي وعشرات الاليات المدرعه والمروحيات
العسكريه ووزير الدفاع يؤكد ان قواته وجهت
ضربات قويه للتنظيمات الارهابيه بجنين على
حد وصفه هذا وافاد شهود عيان بان
المروحيات اطلقت عددا كبيرا من الصواريخ
على ومبان داخل المخيم بينما شرعت جرافات
عسكريه ضخمه بتجريف وتدمير مداخل المخيم
في ردود الفعل الدوليه دانت قطر والاردن
ومصر وايران الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله ودعت المجتمع
الدولي للتحرك فورا لوقف الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه من جانب اخر قال مسؤول
اسرائيلي انهم ابلغوا الامريكيين بالنشاط
العسكري في جنين لكن دون تحديد موعد الى
اللقاء